الى اي مدى ممكن ان نقول بان المجتمع
العلماني في تركيا تراجع في السنوات
الاخيره على حساب هذه الجماعه
من الدستور ولا يزال موجوده على الورق
وقد انتهك بشكل كبير جدا تحت حكم العداله
والتنميه الحكومه على سبيل المثال تستخدمه
السياسيه الحكومه تستخدمه الموارد العامه
همم
تقرب وللاستفاده من الجماعات الدينيه
المنهاج التعليميه الحالي
رموس وافكار دينيه كبيره وقويه لها حكومه
اعضاءها
اصلهم من خلفيه دينيه او اسلاميه ولهذا
السبب يحاولون استخدام السلطه الدوله
لتحويل لان المجتمع همم
مثلا همم
تفضلهم الحكومه بشكل ايجابي همم لا شك هذا
انتهاك لماده العلمانيه المنظمه السياسي
التركي واعتقد بان هذه
المساله مقلقه جدا ولكن الختان
السياسي التركي الى الان عام الماني وحتى
النظام
تاثير جماعه اسماعيل الاغا تحديدا علاقه
بالحمل التي سنه
بعد همم فضه ومحاوله الانقلاب اللي صارت
عام 2016
منهم
لذلك بعد عمليه التطهير الحسبه دي يستبدل
هذه المناصبه باعضاء من جماعات الدينيه
مثلا الى جماعات اسماعيل الاغا وهنا لك
ايضا الحديث عن الجماعات الدينيه اخرى
التي
برزت في تركيا المعاصره فهي عمليه مستمره
بدات
السلطه ولكن تطهير والتخلص من ارتفاع
يقولون فجماعه اخرى بدات تبرز ضمنها
اليوم همم نتائج ذلك